- [Voiceover] Alice fills
up the gas tank of her car
before going for a long drive.
The equation below, and
that should be above.
The equation above models
the amount of gas, g,
in gallons in Alice's car
when she has driven m miles.
What is the meaning of 32 in the equation?
All right, let's look up here.
This is the gallons that
she has left in her car,
and what's going on here?
So it makes sense that,
look, when m is zero,
when she has driven
nothing, she's going to have
15 gallons in her car.
And then as you drive more and more,
you're going to subtract more
and more gallons from her car.
So this is, this term right over here,
this is the number of gallons,
this is the number of gallons used up.
So why are you dividing?
If you have m miles divided
by 32, how do you get gallons?
What do the units on the 32 need to be?
And so, let's just think about this.
If I have miles, so this is miles up here,
and I'm going to be dividing
them by some mystery units,
some mystery units, I need to get gallons.
I need to get, I need to get gallons,
'cause this is going to be
the number of gallons used up.
So what are the mystery units going to be?
Well, we can treat these
units the way we would treat
algebraic, algebraic variables.
So we could solve for units here.
So we could take the
reciprocal of both sides,
and we could say the
units, the mystery units
divided by miles is going
to be one over gallons,
or I guess you could say per gallon.
It's going to be one over gallons,
and then multiply both sides times miles.
Multiply both sides times miles.
You're going to get the mystery units.
The mystery units are going to be,
if you multiply both sides by miles,
and I don't want to get
confused with this over here.
So we multiply both sides by miles,
both sides by miles.
Your mystery units are going to be miles,
miles per gallon.
So this right over here,
the units over here,
in order for this thing
to come out to miles,
in order to come out to gallons,
in the numerator you have m miles
divided by 32 miles per gallon,
miles per gallon.
This is telling you how much mileage
you get per gallon for her
car, how much she is getting.
So let's look at the choices.
Alice uses 32 gallons of gas per mile.
Now we have to be very careful.
It's miles per gallon, not gas per mile.
Alice's tank can hold 32 gallons of gas.
No, Alice's tank can
hold 15 gallons of gas.
She fills up her tank, and
before she's driven anything,
we see here, when m is zero,
she's going to have 15 gallons in her car.
So that's not right.
Alice can drive 32 miles on a tank of gas.
That's right. The units here
are 32 miles per gallon.
So that's that one.
Alice's car can drive
32 miles to the gallon.
Oh, whoa, that was, that
was, that was a close one.
This isn't 32 miles per gallon.
This is 32 miles on a tank of gas.
This would be 32 miles on over 15 gallons.
No, no, that's not right.
Well, that was a close one.
Alice's car can drive 32 miles per gallon.
That's right, 32 miles,
32 miles per gallon.
And if this unit business that I just did,
you find it confusing, one
other way to think about it,
I mean, you could have ruled,
you could have ruled out
something like this, because
when you look at this,
you can see that okay, her tank holds 32,
her tank holds 15 gallons.
You could have tried, you
could have tried this one,
and you would have seen that
the units didn't work out.
If you have 15 gallons,
15 gallons minus m miles
divided by 32, 32 gallons per mile,
32 gallons per mile,
what would the units end up being here,
especially right over here?
You would have miles
divided by gallons per mile.
This is going to be, this is
going to be minus m times,
I guess let me write
it this way, m over 32,
miles times miles per gallon,
miles per, miles per gallon,
and you get miles squared per gallon.
You'd get these crazy units up here.
So, hopefully it makes sense
that we would pick this last choice.
And this one almost got me
when they said tank of gas.
I was thinking, my brain
was thinking gallon.
I was so already
programmed for the answer.
But anyway, yes, the last choice
is what we want to go with.